we were flying through the breathtaking
Hindu Kush mountains with the Duke and
Duchess of Cambridge ahead of us
traveling to some of the most remote
parts of northern Pakistan to draw
attention to a global issue
the Chivo glacier is what William and
Kate had come to see it was the first
time they've seen a melting glacier for
themselves
this one is retreating at a rate of 10
meters a year a rate that is only going
up we've seen around the world now the
young are getting very engaged in what's
going on
and I think it's fantastic that we can
can all come together and really have a
very good conversation about what we
need to do and the action needs to
happen very soon the rising temperatures
are having two major impacts here no
glaciers could mean 1.6 billion people
in this mountain region would lose their
only source of water but also melting
means flooding they flew into the
village of Boone Barret which in 2015
was hit by severe floods and it wasn't
just the water that caused the damage
this was actually the boulders the rocks
and the landslides that came with that
flood in 2015 completely destroying
houses the police station up here also
the agricultural land and that's why the
villagers here are still struggling to
get back on their feet can you ask him
if he fears that climate change and the
flooding is the biggest threats in his
village
by me to local said it was like an
earthquake as the force which shook the
village they are genuinely afraid that
it will happen again we are not feel
safe in Kailash really if raining
started in Kailash evilly we are moved
to mountains to save ourself the kailash
people are just a small community whose
religion predates islam and christianity
and that is what the couple wanted to
remember the decisions we take on
climate change could mean their unique
way of life is under threat Rhiannon
Mills Sky News in the Hindu Kush
mountains